[Music]
president Trump pulled off a diplomatic
coup in the last few days playing host
to French President Emmanuel macron but
first lady Melania Trump has engineered
her own diplomatic triumph Sri cently
first as a dignified White House
representative at the barbara bush
funeral this weekend and then over the
last two days as the flawless hostess of
the French first family including at
tonight's state dinner
wellmaybe Melania will finally get some
of those magazine covers that featured
Michelle Obama so prominently and
frequently but I won't hold my breath to
discuss where all of this were joined by
Fox News contributor Rachel Campos Duffy
along with the publisher of Catalina
magazine Kathy aroo great to see both of
you let's start with you Rachel Melania
has had to endure Jimmy Kimmel mocking
her accent I know he apologized that's
fine but you know she's not gotten the
you know the cover of Vogue five times
in the first year like Michele
exaggerating but you know what I'm
saying right and she's just scrutinized
by in in in every every what she's
holding a president hand or not or it's
endless and yet tonight we see a
beautiful dinner that she did not hire
an event planner for she did it all
herself all the designs all the
selections no Desiree Rogers they're
helping her I guess no I mean remember
if she was a socialite then we assumed
that she had when she was mrs. Trump
living in Manhattan she probably you
know hosted many events and this is her
sort of showcasing what she brings to
the office of first lady I would say or
the position of first lady I would say
that while this has been an amazing
event and it has been flawless you're
absolutely right about that Laura she's
been doing this all along I have been so
impressed with this not just her quiet
dignity as you brought up but also just
this diplomatic use of fashion it's been
brilliant when she went to Paris and to
that restaurant ah meant the Eiffel
Tower she you know she was wearing red
white and blue a symbol of both of the
flags
she wore that gorgeous black caftan with
the gold white belt in Saudi Arabia and
of course who can forget that amazing
Asian inspired gown that she wore China
with the pink first sleeve so she has
been doing this all along I have to say
also you're right Jimmy Kimmel has been
mean so has the fashion industry in
Bravo you don't jacob ana carolina
herrera those who have celebrated
fashion instead of boring us with
another political statement as so many
in the fashion industry have done to
take a stab at her yeah Cathy the
Michelle Obama I don't think I think she
was on the cover of pretty much every
magazine that's ever been published and
good for her she's a beautiful woman
she's a great first lady but Melania
Trump is like gotten like nothing is
from me from the elite fashion industry
or certainly from the entertainment
industry she is from the elite fashion
industry this is a former model so she's
had many covers so we don't want to fear
on another cover I'm talking about the
way ladies are treating she hasn't
really been a traditional first lady
she's been an absolute lady what
happened to being your own person well
there's nothing wrong with that I mean I
think I'm many Americans and when you're
sorry for her we actually feel sorry for
her because of her husband I mean she is
she's gonna start her anti-bullying
campaign and it seems like she's married
to one of the biggest bullies in the
country so she's against the
cyberbullying and she's with a cyber
bully she is put down by Jimmy Kimmel
and meanwhile her husband mocks people
like Jimmy Kimmel so don't you feel
sorry for her so that's okay that's you
happy I think that's really
condescending I really like you I think
you're really fun thanks why is it
condescending because she has no let me
finish because this drives me crazy
about the way people treat Melania she's
made her own choice she made her choice
right she married a Donald Trump I
presume she loved love loves her husband
and and yet the the all these women who
claim to be pro-choice and women should
do what they want any kind of
arrangement for their marriages are good
for them it's all about free choice but
when a conservative woman makes a choice
yet trasher or you say we feel sorry for
and by the way Melania Lola Melania also
responded to the cyberbullying that
she got over her cyber bullying
initiative let's listen I have been
criticized for many commitment to
tackling this issue and I know that will
continue but it will not stop me from
doing what I know is right
Rachel Jenny I mean she's sitting by her
husband's eyes these women coming out
that stormy Daniels I mean we all feel
horrible to be in her shoes to be
married to someone like this we feel we
feel bad from her again that's what she
wants it's condescending and it's
demeaning
I think it's on it I thought I find I
feel sorry I mean that when if you said
that about Hillary Clinton the feminists
would be going crazy they'd be saying oh
how dare you that's her choice anyway
it's between Cathy and themselves it's
about themselves and for you it's not
it's a political statement Rachel a
really quite exactly right Cathy is
being disingenuous she knows exactly
what's happening all of us who have a
brain know exactly what's happening the
fashion wait a minute the fashion
industry Hollywood the mainstream media
they all consider they all consider
Melania and Ivanka complicit in the
election of Donald Trump who hello to
run as a Republican that's what this is
about
it's politics pure and simple Melania
what's right class and it's politics and
they don't like it they won't credibly